Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so Captain America
Civil War Luke Cage all kinds of Easter eggs
for agents of shield careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen episode 10 yet the Hulkbuster
giveaway still going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Marvel related comment on this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything winners
are usually announced at the end of videos
this is all about the patriot's Backstory,
but there are whole bunch of Easter eggs for
Luke Cage and Captain America Civil War as
well as the Captain America comics, so number
10 the Judas bullets from Luke Cage, so the
watchdogs are trying to assassinate the patriot
at least that seems like that's what they're
trying to doing so they might just be trying
to destabilize shield, but it seems like part
of a bigger plan they were teasing a lot of
strings being pulled from behind the scenes,
but the Judas bullets from Luke Cage were
obtained from Hammer tech they were manufactured
based on should Towery tech that had been
left over, so if you don't remember from the
Luke Cage series diamondback is a weapons
merchant who gets all his stuff from Justin
Hammer who was locked up in Seagate prison
along with Luke Cage, so you have to imagine
that Justin Hammer's like sitting in some
cells somewhere still earning billions and
billions of dollars.
Even though he's locked up, but they do make
a couple references to the watchdogs being
very well armed using a lot of left over Hydrotech
so Hydra got a lot of name dropped in this
episode just making it seem like whoever's
behind the watchdogs is left over from Hydro
so we'll talk about that in the second but
gave a Luke Cage references, it's a lot easier
for the TV shows to referenced up on the Netflix
series than it is for them to do stuff in
the movies with characters and stuff, so this
will be fun when iron fist drops in March,
but number nine Daisy in the spotlight an
actual in human unlike the patriot who's getting
a lot of great PR.
So that whole thing, there is then just trying
to ease in human relations slowly pushing
Daisy into the limelight the producers teased
it is totally possible that she could become
the director of shield if the show gets another
season or two.
It just depends on how many seasons it's getting,
but you have to remember that Coulson still
runs the show.
It just that they need a public face all explained
that Coulson twist at the end to the number
eight interrogating the watchdog assassin.
So you get all kinds of Hydra name dropped
she talks about the fridge.
The battle for the fridge that she mentions
was from season one episode 18, but the fridge
was just one of shield facilities where it
locked up a lot of superhumans, so number
seven, he name dropped probabilities analyzing
probabilities your like wait a minute how
many Marvel villains are really good at analyzing
probabilities scarlet which can change probabilities
but they're basically teasing whoever's behind
the watchdogs here this is like laying groundwork
to make some big reveal.
It'll probably be some big character from
the marvel universe that we've seen before.
It has ties to Hydra there couple big candidates,
but because the patriot line flows from the
Captain America comics, just sounds like at
the Captain America character so that might
be Arnim Zola.
He might have somehow survived the destruction
and winter soldier when they blew up the facility
where his mainframe was they implied that
he died, but you have to remember that he
has a digital consciousness.
So he could have escaped and in the comics
he actually uploads himself to this crazy
body.
It looks like this that actually might be
where they're taking the life model decoy
story of the season were like Arnim Zola puts
himself in one of these bodies so that is
something to think about for the future.
You know no idea who the watchdog leader is,
but there's some mysterious benefactor there
ties to Hydra.
This is all Captain America stuff.
So there's a number big candidates Arnim Zola
just fits with that life model decoy stuff
but number six briefcase redshirt that's who
I'm calling this character gets sucked out
the quench a door it was great death very
WTF, but you kinda knew something was happening
when he started talking about things that
had Apsley nothing to do with the tone of
what the scene demanded was this really sad
moment they were talking about an agent that
it died and he went off on this rant about
good PR.
So any time a character that never really
gets any lines and you don't even remember
who they are starts getting a bunch of lines
that have nothing to do with the tone of the
scene.
You know some big twist is coming up so boom
just get sucked right out the door plane goes
down number five the pilot dies firefly.
You know big Joss Whedon Easter egg dies firefly
wash style with the tree branch right through
him.
So if you didn't watch firefly, it's another
big Weeden verse production the pilot Allen
to dig dies just like this.
So shield is a Joss Whedon show they reference
a lot of other Joss Weeden stuff but number
four may flipping her ship in the matrix and
all the jokes about who's more hard-core her
or Aida.
So it goes like full-size lawn she's a bad
ass but so is may, so they figure out that
the matrix simulations they gave her his Apsley
nothing like what she really needs in the
way they describe it like the massage the
acupuncture sounds just like Coulson's implanted
memories of Tahiti so maze Tahiti is the same
as Coulson's Tahiti and they figure out that
that's terrible for the gonna cook up something
really crazy WTF for which when they said
the dragons weren't enough made me think of
Hydra again because what's worse than the
Dragon mythical creature it be a Hydra and
Hydro Captain America the patriot just a lot
of Easter eggs on the show come from the Captain
America universe, so number three life model
decoy may is starting to figure out that she's
a life model decoy they explain it's all subconscious,
so she's starting to flip her ship.
She notices the metal endoskeleton.
So it's like wait a minute, terminator what
the hell's going on here.
So that's gonna play out over the next couple
of episodes, but number two patriot Backstory
reveal Captain America Civil War Easter eggs
super soldier serum program so they name dropped
the first kind program which is the name of
the scientist the crazy the super soldier
serum in that first Captain America movie.
But then they say that they actually made
their version of the serum from daisies father's
formula.
Calvin Savo, so there might be some big holdout
moment because he said they took most of the
bad stuff out in his version of the formula
which is a little more raw just made him to
his Apsley go nuts, so there might be a moment
like that from the patriot down the road that
I was kind of hoping at some point that he
will get to wield Captain America's actual
shield just because it's now in possession
of the US government because Captain America
isn't using it anymore because he is in Captain
America at least until infinity war will see
but they do bust out Coulson's energy Captain
America shield every once in a while the pop
that out the Jeffrey Mays version of the patriot
is actually someone from the World War II
era Captain America comics from way back.
The just took up the mantle of eventually
so he didn't have any special powers.
He was just a bad ass.
The other version.
They combined him with the TV show was the
Elijah Bradley patriot character.
So there been a couple people to where the
title of Captain America been a couple people
to where the title of the patriot so the Elijah
Bradley patriot is somebody from present day
that uses artificial means to give himself
power but he took pills instead of the serum.
So that's kind of the thing they're going
with.
In this.
So this version of the character is just a
couple different versions combined but just
explain the Captain America Civil War Easter
eggs, so when he talks about the big blast
in Vienna that was the blast to kill Black
Panthers father so he was just like a normal
shield agent that was working there.
He help someone by accident.
They thought that he was this big hero.
So he just rolled with it, then Talbot called
because he knew that shield was coming back
they needed somebody in charge that had powers
that was enhanced to sort of like he's PR
between Inhumans and normal people and someone
that they could control.
So the patriot was following their orders
the whole time.
But now number one he's going to stay in charge
Coulson is really taking over, though Nick
fury style from the shadows.
Nick fury still out there somewhere.
We haven't really seen them in a while but
that's mostly because Samuel L Jackson's contract
is really expensive so he still out there
somewhere pursuing X Hydra agents he'll probably
show back up during infinity war with the
other big thing.
The other number one is fits downloading eight
is mainframe from the one that revolted.
So she was actually normal.
She was only obeying or programming, so that
sounds like it's going to be the back door
to Radcliffe taking advantage of fits to get
his hands on the dark hold benefits try to
do something good, but unwittingly playing
into Radcliffe's plans to get his hands on
the dark cold.
So you guys can let me know what was your
favorite moment from the episode what you
think about all the Easter eggs for Captain
America and who do you think is the evil head
of the watchdogs this like secretly controlling
things it just has to be some Captain America
character and feels like they're building
toward some big reveals like oh my God we
haven't seen this person in forever, but big
news about the schedule, so the schedule is
gonna get crazy with videos next week, just
because there's so much stuff that's happening
on Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday so I'm have
to rearrange when videos post.
So depending on what we know what people think
about shield going forward.
It people still really enjoy the videos also
keep making them.
But if I have to I'll just post stuff to Facebook
because it is really fun to pull through all
the Easter egg just like go through everything
and try to tie it all together so that might
take on some form on my Facebook page if it
needs to the some schedule problem what can
happen is is this is like the tentative schedule
for next week that that doesn't include like
Monday Saturday Sunday are like the other
days is really just Tuesday to Thursday this
going to be the nightmare for my schedule
so that might change a little bit.
I'll just keep people updated as I post new
videos in the next couple days and if you
didn't see it I did a video about Marvel's
other new TV show X-Men Legion, it's a Marvel
TV collaboration that's going to be on Wednesday
nights.
So it'll be a Thursday video.
It's not starting till February 8 but I'll
post a link to the trailer at the end of this
a did a video kind of explaining the series
is gonna be crazy intense ill be on FX networks
in the United States.
It'll be on Fox's international channels.
If you live outside the United States, everybody
will be able to watch it on the same day the
giveaway time.
Congratulations to this week's hope Buster
giveaway winner Mr. gaming wolf please private
message me on the back end of my channel so
I can get your contact details.
So I'll announce the winner the next time
I post a shield video or if that moves to
Facebook I'll just announce the winner on
my Facebook page.
Don't worry will figure it out.
So next video will be guardians of the galaxy
to have some new Game of thrones season 7
that I want to post and there's probably gonna
be some new arrow footage tomorrow to while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here for new Marvel defenders which is actually
coming really soon and you can click here
for the X-Men Legion trailer.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!